BARRY TROTZ WILL NOT BE ON T T
TWO FOR
>> Brendan: TALK ABOUT A LOTO D.
TO THE NET,D PLAY GOES ABOUT
HIS BUSINESS ON THE POWER PLAY,.
NO, THAT GOES OFF OF THE BACK OF
TEAMMATES.
TWO ON ONE.ER
PAGEAU BREAKING THROUGH THE KEI
JOB OF KOSKINEN.
>> Butch: IT ALLOWED H ARENA ONR
KOEKKOEK.
BEAUVILLIER GAVE IT BACK TO
HI
OPPORTUNITIES.
ANDERS LEE, A NICE LITTLE T TCT
>> Butch: I THINK YOU HAVE TO
PICK UP CON YORE EARLIER THAN  .
PARESEN
THE BENCH TODAY.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED AT THE START OF
THE GAME HE WOULD NOT
LATER, KOEKKOEK.
JOHNSTON JOINED CZARNIK.
AT HANG
AROUND IN CASE I CAN GET A
LITTLE BIT OF AHE GAME.
>> Brendan: DRAISAITL.
NOT INTERESTING THAT HE
WOULD GO TO NURSE ON PROTECTING
NURSE FROM UP IN THE CORNER.
PAGEAU, STEERS IT OUT  HIM TO
CALM DOWN.
5:21 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK HERE
INBARZAL GOT TOPSIDE.
TAKE A LOOK. BY
KOSKINEN AS THAT WAS A
TREMENDOUS SHIFT DOBSON.
HERE'S PAGEAU.NT, DNOW AS WE LOT
PARESE IS COMING WITH IT.
LOOKING FOR HELP, SCORES!
IS